You
Your left ear
Is it buzzing like before
Is it a buzz or is it or is it the AC?
Okay, good
Because I'm like that squishmallow is far away. I don't know
Alright, so you hear my AC from time to time
Yes, this spyware squishmallow
I'm gonna give some time for people to come in and chat with you guys
Yeah
I feel like I'm still too quiet though, even when I talk real close to the microphone
I don't want it to be too loud though
The kitties are quite fine
They're doing very very very well
Maybe it was actually by my feet right now I moved her bed so she could be close to me
Is that too loud or is that just right
Okay
It sounds bad
Choppy
It was reverb
I don't know why
There's echo
You hear an echo
Oh wait that's
I still have the echo on
Yeah, I was still on the church settings whoa
I think that's why
Oh my
I forgot about the church settings
I suppose the church did make everything quieter
I
Sorry to smack the microphone
Monk
Yeah, I ate my leftovers today. That's what I ate
I ate my leftovers
They were very tasty
And now my AC is gone
I have nothing for tomorrow. No, I still I only had I only had half of it. I still have so much food left
I see fit me tell it to me straight. I'm gonna not gonna turn into you're turning into a furry. I'm so sorry
You have been diagnosed with furry
Um I had
I had for food. I just had leftover
Um Hibachi
The being furry is terminal
I'm so sorry there's not much I can do for you
You are a lost cause
She we would know she's been diagnosed that's a lie that is not true
He is just staring at me from the floor in her bed
Those ears I'm a bunny girl. That's different from being a furry if I was a furry
I'd be completely anthropomorphic like the bunny girl from Zootopia
But I'm not
Would you like hold on I also added some stuff to my stream deck so now I can do this
Do you like my outfit
I
Yeah, sorry boy
You see
You got some Tom Tom
I
See I think I
Now just add the whip
I'm gonna get you I'm gonna get you
I have a little friend I'm gonna pretend it's you
Oh
Jump scare
It looks like the Tom Lungachi you're right look it's our kid. It's our child
Goodbye child
What up what up look what else I can do
I deleted the baby the baby gone. How do I put my arms down
There we go
The head stays attached indeed
You need to turn half right no you will all you will turn full furry. I'm so sorry
Was our child's infernal screams a secret tingle no I have the secret tingles right here
You still don't know what it is what I'm tapping though
Skyrim werewolf
Can you guess what it is
That's correct it is a bowl
A chalkboard oh my god you want me to kill you
Sounds like plastic it's actually not a litter box. Yes the secret is a litter box
No, that's not it you'll just have to wait and see you'll just have to wait and see
Is it a metal bowl does that sound like metal to you
Use litter box yes, that's actually besides me
It is not plastic
Yeah, I'm gonna hold it while you pee it's not plastic
It's a gamer soups ball
All right you guys you guys can stop stop guessing I'll just let me tweet out that I'm alive
And we'll get started
Guys ten sixteen K people have seen my feet on main that's crazy
I
First I see then strong you know I'm doing ASMR
I'm
People like usually when we all realize that we all have ASMR that day
We'd like I was gonna do like Hades instead, but then I saw it in the
Calendar and I'm like oh, I'll just do ASMR so we can have an impromptu ASMR train
Because yeah, I think and I think I see got the idea too because I saw that strong it ASMR so I'm like
Oh, let me let me do ASMR people who if like strong he wants to read me
And then I think I see changed your thing to ASMR
Yeah, it's pretty good. I like it. It's a good
ASMR train on yes precisely
My chair closer
Semi-planned yeah, we didn't like talk about it
Yeah, yeah, you like that
That was it was a good idea strong he came up with that and it makes sense for us to do those
So I'm like so we just kind of did it today without thinking about it
All right
We're starting we're starting
Oh, we're getting rated the
One sometimes it doesn't show
Hi everybody. Hello. Hi. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hi. Hi. Let me get close to you
Hi
Hi raiders. Hi. Hello
Hello raiders. My name is she be cotton mom and we're just about to start the stream
Start the ASMR I will be taking care of you while you're sick. I
Really really hope you enjoy
Hello, my main reeflings
I
Hello raiders. Hi. Hi
Welcome in welcome in. I
Hope that you would um that you'll decide to stick around and hang out and spend time with me and continue listening to some ASMR
while you fall asleep and
Get comfy
We'll be doing some whispering some tapping some secret triggers that I will surprise you with that
I think a lot of you will enjoy and
I just want you to let me pamper you and take care of you. I
Can't sleep. I'm at work too bad sleep. Hello. It was weird over there
I'm sure as Johnny is probably
Either passing out, but make sure get some water
I'll make up you make sure you get up and stretch and we're about to get into it
Hello raiders. Hi
So this will be don't fall asleep while you're driving. So this will be a role play ASMR
Um, I will be interacting with the chat still
But I have some triggers lined up and here we go
We are starting
I
Hope what are you doing here? I didn't think you would get hope so early sweetheart
You think you're sick
Did you get sick
It was from that rainy day the other day wasn't it
I wonder if you caught a cold or if you eat something bad
Let me just finish up
this one sentence
The script I'm writing
And then I'm gonna check on you, okay
Okay, come here come here come here come here come here come here come here
Come here come here come here come here come here
There you are
You threw up did you your boss sent you home?
Let me come hold on. Let me let me get a look at you. Let me
Let me check on you over here
Feel kind of warm you're saying your tummy hurts
Mm-hmm, I don't know. I don't know sweetheart. What other symptoms are you having?
Oh
You feel weak and drowsy you have a bad headache
Come come lay on the bed with me. Come lay down
Come lay down you better come come lay down with me
Yes, you're right there
There
Okay, let me just get behind you
I'll rub your back, okay, and then you can tell me what happened and what you think causes
All right
Do you promise to be honest sweetheart?
You promise
Okay
Lay down just like so
And I'll take care of you, okay
Let me rub your back and you can tell me about your day
You feel like you have a nose
I
You're making sure that you're sitting up straight when you're out of your desk at work
I'm sorry. I didn't know it was so tender for you right there. Let me go in a different spot
You have to make sure that you sit up straight at work sweetheart. This isn't good for you to slouch
It's probably causing you to make you feel even worse than you already are
How does that feel? Does that feel better?
Let me try on the other side
Looks like you have a knot right here
You think I poisoned you? Only with my love. It's so good
Yes, I love you so so much. The lunch that I made for you this morning
I secretly put something in it so you would get sick and come home and spend time with me
I'm kidding. That would never hurt you
You think I'm crazy or something? Yeah, I'm crazy about you but I wouldn't do that to you sweetheart
I think I would choose to go for a couple of knots from your back. Does that make you feel a little bit better?
Just a little bit
Okay, turn around so I can give you a smooch
Now I got your face in my hands and I'm gonna smooch you better
Okay, let me take your temperature
I have the thermometer right here
Let's see what your temperature is
Alright, it's saying you have a fever
Oh no, my goodness
Well, I kissed you on the cheek. I didn't kiss you on the mouth
What to do? What to do? It seems like you have a fever
You might have the flu if you're feeling nauseous
Why don't you lay back on the bed?
My cat was scratching the cat scratcher
I'll make a compress for you, okay? And I'll give you some medicine
Okay, I'll be right back. Want to go get that for you?
Okay, I'm back sweetie
The compress
I'm just gonna lay it like this
You're not her bird, sweetie
I'm only doing what you would do for me
Let me get this side
I'm gonna kind of sweat a little
Is it cool when you turn around a little bit?
Okay
Don't worry
I still love you even with your messy hair
Okay
I think I look cute today, thank you
Alright, let me comb your hair, oh just so it's not all in your face
Let me wiggle behind you real quick
Surprise kiss
What if I tickle you?
What did I do with the brush?
There it is
I got this brand new brush
Sounds quite nice, doesn't it?
And I haven't even started brushing your hair yet
Probably gonna feel wonderful on you
Alright, let me brush your hair
On your face
You can always rely on me
Take care of you
Let me get right over
Surprise kiss
Sorry, Reina's singing the song over people
Reina
If you're new here, Reina is one of my three cats
I'll wear three cats, my love
Maybe I'll get Reina over here and give you guys some purrs
Hi Reina
Have you come to check on Howard to see if they're doing okay?
Did you want to get some purrs, Reina?
Did you want to go home and see the cat purrs?
Everybody knows you got the best healing purrs, Reina
Come here, come here
Reina
You're thinking about it
Take care of your cat
There we go
Time for some healing purrs
Reina
Reina came to see you to make sure you're okay
Let's get some purrs on the other side
Reina
Thank you Reina
Thank you for your healing purrs, Miss Reina
Everybody's saying thank you to Reina
I'm going to finish brushing your hair
It's always good to get some kitty purrs when you're sick
They have healing frequencies
They purr the same frequency as your bones healing
Let's get back together, did you know that?
This is more crazy
Reina
I smell good because I shower today
I wash with the lush intergalactic soap
It has sparkles in it so my skin is sparkly
It's just like a vampire
I'm going to suck your blood
Surprise kiss
Over here
I think your hair is fixed
I hope that makes you feel a little bit better
What do you think you need?
Do you need me to get you anything in particular?
I like snuggling with you
You want chicken soup and ginger ale?
Water and hugs?
I'll get you anything you want
Want to be the small spoon?
I'll let you be the small spoon
I just want you to feel better
You two being silly?
Sorry
My internet seems fine so it must be you too
What would you want?
How about we hydrate you?
I think you need to be hydrated
Being hydrated is very important
Let me get you a ginger ale
Do you want a ginger ale?
Okay
I got the ginger ale
Extra spicy just for you
Extra gingery just for you
Swaps
I actually have something spicy
I'm really sick to burn it out here
Swaps
Trying to move
That was a 3D or something
Swaps
Was that loud?
Hear that fiddle?
Hear the sizzle of the ginger ale?
Swaps
This ginger ale is extra sizzly
Bird feed you the ginger ale?
Swaps
Are you going to drink it or what? You've just been listening to it sizzle
You can taste the sizzle
Ready? Open your mouth
Very good
I'll give you a break
I don't want you choking on this
After this I'll prepare you a very special soup
Are you ready?
What's in the soup? It's a secret
Swaps
I think it's time to prepare the soup
Don't you leave and get up
I said I'll make the soup
I have lots of ingredients to add
I have my big wooden spoon
No no no I don't need any help
You just lay down and I'll take care of it
And I have my wood bowl
Swaps
What kind of soup?
Special soup
It's time to make the soup
Let me just put in some spices
Some liquid spices
It's very new
I hope the ingredients aren't too loud when I put them in
They smell good
I should probably pour in the broth first
Pour in the broth before the other stuff
Pour in the broth
The broth has been poured
The secret ingredient is my love
Time to pour in the ingredients
Out of the way
Can you guess what the soup is?
Water
That's how it works
Thanks for watching!
Don't forget to like and subscribe!
I should probably put the spoon away.
How do you hear my tummy noises when you're on my chest?
Riddle me that, Batman.
Maybe because I have the toot.
I mean, it's not as loud.
Alright, stop.
Hi.
I just want you to fall asleep listening to my heartbeat.
I hope you feel better soon.
I don't want you to be sick for so long.
I care about you a lot.
And I know you take care of me this way.
If I was sick.
So of course I'm going to take care of you.
I just want you to fall asleep listening to my heartbeat.
And make sure you feel quickly enough.
Thanks for watching!
I hope you guys had a nice night today.
I'm going to introduce you.
Mine is not far in the backhand.
And I'm just going to be talking a little bit.
I think I might ask for an editor.
I'm going to be talking about ASMR videos.
So I'm going to go a little bit more.
I think I'm going to do most of the dialogue.
And it could boost the volume too.
I could do that.
I got it.
Thanks for watching!
Thanks for listening to my dream.